so
time to wake up
how is she she's great you're picking
her up today right
of course it's my day
missed you so much why does time go so
fast when i'm with you
time flies when we're having fun
zoe sorry
where is she now i have to do an
emergency surgery she has
intracranial bleeding i spoke to the
doctor again
he said that most of the bleeding
occurred that night what can we
do nothing but you were always the one
saying when there's no more hope just
keep on going
you know i realized something terrible
about you after she was born
your needs come first because i wanted
to go back to work a year after she was
born
six months so what i wouldn't give up
she's gone listen to your heart isabel
i just thought we could help each other
never let go over
hello ah dr fisher nice to see you again
so
how can i help you she's my daughter she
died two days ago
i can't bring back the dead it doesn't
bother you morally
no even if it works it will not be her
the color of her hair her smile even
when she likes or dislikes
all that is written in ourselves girl
talk
v
you